do you think men cheating and women
cheating is the exact same thing no I
may not cheat with goddamn anything like
oh my gosh no no cheers
this is like that's what the women say
on my show not all not all
not every man but okay come on so you're
in Tiger Woods position yes and every
day you come home and there's a Bus full
of models just waiting begging begging
you to come home with them now you might
you may be a good man and every day you
might say no no no no no no you're
telling me you're telling me in 10 years
you're not going to slip up once like
man's only human most guys just aren't
in that position so most guys when
they're like well not all it's like are
you are you in the position where women
are begging to sleep with you